i think you should work towards a life
that embodies
your values whatever that is so if that
involves close relationships and
altruism and that kind of thing
then that's the kind of life you should
lead but but you shouldn't do it because
you need those things to make you happy
and you're unable to
enjoy your life without them
you start your book off with this quote
from harare which says
in the past we humans learned to control
the world outside us
but we had very little control over the
world inside us
does this highlight a blind spot that
lots of people have
i definitely think so i think we're
naturally wired to pay attention to
what's outside of us and i think there
are potentially good biological reasons
for this right we we have desires
specifically to motivate us to go out
there and try to achieve them
but a lot of thinkers uh sort of within
practical philosophy
the stoics the buddhists right these
these thinkers
have suggested that a better path to
satisfaction and well-being
is to work on what's going on inside
your mind rather than just trying to get
what you want
right so trying to manipulate and master
your own desires
rather than just gratifying them right
trying to make the changes
in your own mind so that you don't
suffer so that you don't have the
these uh biases so that you're you can
restructure your
actions and your behavior so this book
is is really sort of meant to take that
idea
and sort of provide the nuts and bolts
uh
21st century manual for it uh and and
sort of expanding on this idea
um in in a very modern sort of way
yeah because the stoicism and the
buddhism stuff's lovely
but if all it took was confucius quotes
to get yourself to enlightenment
we wouldn't need cbt we wouldn't need to
have
uh neuroscientists and all of the weird
and wonderful sciences that we've
developed over the last few hundred
years
sure and and what i kind of realized was
that the
these ancient words of these thinkers um
really haven't
uh their ideas the reason they've stuck
around is because they're really based
on a lot of science that they just
didn't have access to yet
so these ancient ideas are kind of these
snippets of open source
cognitive code that there's actually
starting to be a neuroscience
basis for but you know
human nature existed pretty much as it
does today
uh many years ago so so we can study
these ancient ideas
and sort of combine them with the modern
ideas to to get to
uh something like a science for
modifying and improving your own mind
yeah what were the main influences for
you what were the bodies of work that
you drew upon to write this
so in the ancient side stoicism is
pretty huge
uh epictetus marcus aurelius these
thinkers
there's also a lot of buddhism and
taoism
that shows up and then sort of sort of
gradually working
chronologically up and arriving to a lot
of the modern science like cognitive
behavioral
therapy um and and other proven
methods of of change in in terms of
your mind um so some neuroscience
in there and uh a lot of affective
behavioral cognitive science all mixed
in
you say that there's a gap between skill
and wisdom
what do you mean so essentially our
culture really trains us to be good at
uh developing knowledge and
implementing it in ways that are good
for uh
industry basically i mean the education
system is all about
learning the knowledge that that they
want you to have
and learning how to uh kind of be
obedient
and be employable right but it doesn't
teach you
how to be happy it doesn't focus on how
to actually
organize your mind or develop these
psychological skills
right we've got therapy for people who
are
you know so far below the level of
psychological adequacy that it can kind
of lift them up
but we don't have that kind of
institution for taking you higher than
that
the closest thing that we have is the
the world of self-help which
has some gems in it and a lot of fluff
and
inspirational nonsense right so um
so really i've i've i've really kind of
made it my mission to create
that that body of information
on a systematic level for how you how
you cultivate
wisdom how you actually get better
at at programming yourself for life not
just
for work not just for uh knowledge or
skills
what's the goal with psychitecture then
which is the
term that you've coined in your book
so the the ultimate goal of
psychotecture
is to get closer and closer to your
ideal self and and to embodying those
values and ideals
so i really kind of leave it as sort of
a blank canvas
i don't tell you exactly where you need
to go because that
depends on your own individual values
so initially when i started writing i i
sort of thought that
we wanted to get rid of all of the you
know negative emotion and disturbance
uh kind of like you see in stoicism
right
uh and that's very much a big part of it
i i think
you know the the negative emotions are a
big part of what stand in our way
of really living a life to our potential
and living a
a good life but i also don't think
that's necessarily the
ultimate end is just to get rid of bad
feelings right i think you could live a
better life
by you know working towards becoming
your ideal self if you
reflected on your life at the end i
don't think you would necessarily
believe
that the life where you suffered the
absolute least was the best
possible life right so
so really you know there's sort of three
realms
that i examine in the book there's the
cognitive realm
the emotional realm and the behavioral
realm so you're
you're looking at developing better
views more accurate views of the world
getting rid of your biases and the
distortions and judgment
that sort of plague your perception
you're looking at getting rid of
emotions that are
maladaptive or that stand in your way of
living
what you believe to be a great life and
then you're looking at behaviors and
habits and actions
so so really all of these take a very
systematic
view and say look the things that are
happening in your mind
they're not just single events they're
all ultimately
interconnected i call it psychological
software
you've got this series of algorithms
that all
connect together and this is really what
all these different types of science
show in their own particular realms
whether you're looking at habit change
or you're looking at
cognitive therapy we find that our
thoughts and our actions and our
emotions
are intricately but intimately tied
together
and and triggering one another and in
order to actually make
changes to them we have to really
understand these connections between
them
why did you give them the particular
order that you do
because although they are separate they
are almost hierarchical
so one of the biggest reasons for this
is that for example if you look at
emotions and the reason why we have
these negative emotions
in many cases it's because we have these
biases
these cognitive distortions that trigger
them so that the cognitive realm
comes first because it's sort of
foundational to the later realms
right if you can get good at identifying
distorted beliefs in your own mind
and actually countering them and
replacing them with better beliefs
you'll have the the basic skills that
you need to be able to build on them
and and master your emotions and change
your habits and all of these
so they they do sort of build on one
another um
like you said is that why do you think
eliezer yukowski's just got like the
the fattest foundation of the pyramid
ever
yes yes i think so um i've always loved
uh les wrong in that whole community
it's it's always sort of been one of the
the components of my vision for
designing the mind
to sort of take that type of community
that's so focused on
optimization of of beliefs and biases
and apply it to more than just beliefs
apply it to
uh behaviors and particularly i think
emotions because the same
kind of logic applies there why do you
think it is
that we don't have a lesswrong.com
for the other two sections have you
thought about that
i think i think there are sort of
similar things for behavior
uh there's a lot of talk about habit
change out there
i mean james clear you know his all of
his work and his book atomic habits
uh very much examines the uh
that side of it but it's
kind of something i've always wondered i
i don't know exactly why
there is that gap because i look at like
the
the community centered around biohacking
for example
people taking all these chemicals and
psychedelics and
injecting themselves with gene altering
materials and microchips
and there's something really cool about
it even though it's uh
there's a bit some some risk there but
i've always wondered why does that
community
on centered around optimizing your whole
psychological software not exist
and and that's kind of that's kind of
where i'm trying to come in there
i get it man i mean for anyone that is
uninitiated
uh lesswrong.com and uh was it
overcomingbias.com as well was that
another one
uh and then slate star codex which is
now
astral codex 10 or something
yeah yeah um so all of these different
websites are born out of this sort of
rationality movement
and if you want to go down a fantastic
blog hole
just go and have a little bit of a look
because i've i've had i've read some of
the best work i've ever
ever seen robin hansen eliader yukowski
and scott alexander are titans
absolute titans and this stuff's just
out there they just do it because they
they need to write some words on on a
page which is unbelievable but yeah i
would be interested
to work out why it is that we don't have
that same level of
community and and passion around stuff
that isn't just rationality i wonder
whether
um it's a bias toward the personality
type of the people that go onto those
websites
whether they tend to be quite rational
utilitarian scientific sort of praying
at the altar of science themselves
and that fits in quite easily with the
worldview whereas if you were to say
okay
now let's talk about how you're actually
acting in the real world or okay
let's actually talk about how your
emotions are feeling and uh
doing the metacognition sort of
self-look
um i wonder whether that might make it
be a step in
an uncomfortable direction for for
people i think that's possible
and i will note that like if you really
spend time on those blogs you will see
that they are
they do pay some attention to those
other areas
as well but i think all of it is pretty
new i mean really before the internet
you had scholars studying these things
but you didn't have these sort of diy
mind hackers who were all getting
together and and trying to optimize
themselves
so i think it may just be that it's all
kind of new and that just happens to be
the community that caught on
yeah but that's a good one i think i
think the desire is there i do think
once people
see it and can visualize it they'll
they'll want to be a part of that kind
of thing
yeah before we start trying to improve
our source code
you say that we need to develop our
metacognition how can we do that
so metacognition is the term i generally
use
mainly because mindfulness has kind of
become this cultural
fad and there's all these different
definitions no one quite knows what it
means
so i'm i'm very specifically talking
about knowing
what's going on inside yourself i've
always been
a pretty strong on this side and and
less aware of
like what's going on around me in the
world and a
sense of direction all of that but it
seems like most people
really need to sort of cultivate greater
metacognition and
this is why the mindfulness movement has
gotten so big it's because people
recognize
that they aren't paying enough attention
to what's going on in their mind
so meditation is one tool for doing this
i think uh like walking mindfulness is
is more along
the path that i've taken i love going on
walks and just reflecting
and introspecting um but essentially you
are
trying to become aware of your own
thoughts and feelings because
if you aren't you've got little hope at
actually modifying them
if you don't know what thought you're
going through let's say that you
you know don't realize for hours until
you know
this has already passed that you were
going through this whole ruminative
spiral where you were
having all these self deprecating
thoughts
and that were just triggering emotions
and kind of spiraling out of control
if you don't know that's happening until
way after the fact you're not going to
be able to step in and intervene
whereas a lot of these things that
people get told they can only
get a little better at managing when it
comes to their emotions
you actually can sort of bypass many of
these
emotional experiences if you can catch
them quickly enough
and sort of do what's necessary to alter
that
emotional trajectory yeah you talk about
something you give it a different name
but the mindfulness gap basically a a
brief beat in between stimulus and
response
and cultivating that i said it on an
episode the other week
cultivating that if i get no closer to
nirvana from my meditation practice
than having that mindfulness gap a
couple of percent more than i used to
i'm going to consider it a win um so you
mentioned that
sitting meditation also walking
meditation which is kind of just
introspection and
looking at the texture of your own mind
how do people take their metacognition
off the cushion so to speak how do we
get it from the walking session within
that i feel real mindful
um texture of my mind is very very plain
and easy to me
how do i get that expanded out into my
bosses just shouted at me or i'm stuck
in traffic
right i think if you can
really build the habit of keeping a log
of what's going on in your mind
instead of just noticing it when you're
on the cushion like you said
if you can get to where you're trying to
notice as quickly as possible and
actually write down
uh the the mental experiences that
you're having
this will cause you to start seeing
these patterns all over the place
right a lot of people don't know what's
what's actually causing the majority of
their daily suffering
right and you may start writing these
things down and realize oh my god
like like 90 of the times that i'm
getting upset
i'm waiting in traffic right and it's
the specific
thought chain that is triggering all
this so if i can
focus on that and program it out and i
can notice when it's happening then i
can eliminate that huge
huge emotional category that i that
isn't serving me and that i don't want
so if you can do this habit of actually
writing down and sort of
categorizing and clustering these these
different experiences
writing down the event that triggered it
the uh
the thought or belief that is sort of
catalyzing it and the emotion you felt
and then you can even get more advanced
and this is a cbt method of actually
identifying the
distortion in that thought and the
correct belief that you want to replace
it with
right if you can just keep this log
you'll start noticing these patterns and
even just noticing
uh can often be enough to get rid of
these things that's a good point
that one of the things anyone that's
doing a headspace is take
ten like the most basic thing the andy
puddy [ __ ] lovely baldy andy puddy come
with his nice soft voice
um the first thing that he gets you to
do is he just wants you to note
just note what it is there is something
happening in the texture of your mind
and as sam harris says being lost in
thought while you're awake is like
dreaming without knowing that you're
dreaming
that's absolutely that's the danger and
as soon as you step through that
and think right okay i can step into my
programming i'm not at the mercy of the
next thought that comes careening into
view remembering that not only are you
not your thoughts you're also
not the creator of your thoughts either
you're the person that sees or hears
them
so you're it's the same as letting
somebody else
constantly talk at you if you don't give
that mindfulness gap
so yeah i dude i am i i think it's a
great way
to kind of set that foundation so you
start off in this
cognitive section how can people rewire
their cognitive biases
so the short answer is it's really hard
to do
[Laughter]
this is what the research suggests and i
do think the research is a little bit
limited on this
but a lot of people think that if they
just learn the names of all the biases
that it'll kind of just magically make
them go away and in some cases
that's true that's why i recommend
before you do anything
learn to identify these pretty much
universal biases
that cause us to make these mistakes and
hold false beliefs
if you can just do that as a first step
it will help improve things what are
your top
three top five okay confirmation bias
is a huge one it's hard to even call
that
just one bias it's more like a cluster
of them but
the whole tendency to want to seek out
information that reaffirms
your existing beliefs that that's huge
i mean if you can get to where when
you're researching an issue
because you're arguing with a friend you
can at least notice
okay i'm i'm tailoring my google search
a little bit towards
showing me what i want to see i'm
clicking on certain links and not
others right this can can help work
towards getting rid of that one
another is this whole mess of social
biases
right we want to fit in we want to be a
part of a group
and this has a tendency to cause us to
skip over a lot of the
logical steps and arguments and to sort
of
find a way to believe what will allow us
to fit in
so this is sort of a fundamental desire
between
behind a lot of our beliefs and then
another
sort of fundamental one is our tendency
to
to want to absolve ourselves of blame
and blame others
so the fundamental attribution that was
my one month that was the one i was
gonna give you
that gets me every time yeah so
so we we just constantly tend to say
well
the reason i was late the reason why i
made this mistake is because the world
was
out to get me i got in traffic right the
reason why someone else
is late is because they're just a bad
person there
that's a bit of an extreme exaggeration
but
that's essentially what we do we want so
badly to preserve this positive
view of ourselves that will will tell
ourselves just about anything
and i'm not saying that you should go
against that to the point of uh
having terrible low self-esteem right
the point is to
develop an accurate view of yourself so
that you can actually work towards
improving yourself okay so we've got
some understanding a little glossary of
mental models that are commonly going to
come up how do we then go about rewiring
our cognitive biases
and what i say on this is that it's it's
sort of a
process it's sort of a creative design
process for every
individual bias and i go through a few
of them
uh but one of them as an example is
uh the planning fallacy right we we have
a tendency to think
we can get something done in a much
shorter time than we actually can
all right you can look at you know
studies have been done on on
classrooms where they ask people like
okay this is the due date for this paper
what are you what day are you 90 done
you're going to have it
have it done by 90 sure you're going to
have it completed by
what are you 50 sure and inevitably
they're so much more
ambitious than they actually end up
doing right
so daniel kahneman who's who's generally
kind of
cynical about the ability to rewire
biases he
even says you can actually rewire this
one and the way to do it
is to look to distributional information
objective information so basically stop
trusting
your intuitions about how long it will
take to get this thing done
and start asking yourself how long has
it taken in the past
how long has it taken me how long does
it generally take other people
it's it's likely going to be a few times
longer than you estimate
right i mean my natural my natural
thinking was that i was going to be able
to finish
my book in six months in reality i it
took me
close to two years right so uh
but i knew at the time when i was
setting that goal like i'm probably not
gonna hit this
but uh so i'm not gonna like go
promoting that it's gonna be ready in
six months uh
so you just have to keep that in mind
that
it is uh it is more about how long it
generally takes
uh than how long you feel like it's
going to take at the time
did you see daniel kahneman with sam
harris that live
event that they did and sam asks this
nobel prize winning
psychologist of like 50 years or 40
years or something just a
total monster in the psychology world
and he says
so after all of this time daniel
researching cognitive biases and
understanding how our minds work
have you actually got yourself any
closer to rationality and he just goes
no not really
yeah i did i did hear that
it is uh and and that's enough to
uh lead most people to think well you
just can't do this
uh what gives me optimism is that
in a lot of these studies pretty much
all of these studies they're finding
people who are
volunteering to be in the study to get
rid of a bias
and they're they're doing it for class
credit or to get paid or whatever it is
all right most people aren't that deeply
motivated to get rid of
anchoring bias or whatever it is they're
kind of just going along with the study
if you look at cognitive therapy which
is essentially
the process of getting rid of biases for
emotional purposes
right where people are often meeting
with a therapist
once a week on these issues they're
doing these homework assignments
they really want to improve their own
minds we find
a totally different finding it's not
impossible to change these these beliefs
it's actually pretty common it's very
effective
to work on these beliefs and and then
get rid of the
negative emotions and mood disorders
that were propagated by the beliefs
so to me that tells me that the
motivation of the person working on
themselves
plays a really big role and i i think
that's missing from a lot of the studies
that suggest we can't change our biases
some skin in the game as well right you
know if your
life is falling to pieces and you're
paying somebody 50
an hour to put it back together you're
probably gonna
work fairly hard to try and get it fixed
what about introspection how can people
improve their introspection
so that's a great question i think
mindfulness
plays a pretty big role um i read a book
called
insight which is all about introspection
and it finds that
introspection can actually cloud
people's judgment if you're not doing it
properly
one of the findings tasha urich
she covers the way that you ask yourself
questions plays a big role in how how
much introspective clarity
you can get so the people who tend to
ask themselves
why did i do this why did this happen
who are essentially looking for
a simple cause effect explanation
these are the ones who who typically go
wrong and go astray when they're trying
to get clarity
because just like in the world of
rationality in science just like the the
ancients like natural philosophers who
thought the earth was made up of four
elements
it's natural for all people to jump on
whatever conclusion they come to first
and want to stick to it so i think i
think
that's what most people do wrong when
they introspect is they come up with a
theory for why
am i this way why do i keep doing this
and they tell themselves
the first story that pops into their
heads whereas
if you can actually step back and ask
ask what questions
ask what's going on in my mind and
observe it and use
mindfulness or metacognitive awareness
to actually
understand this chain of events going on
you can get a lot more clarity
so just just stopping imposing a
narrative
when you look at your mind and just
seeing what actually happened
is a huge way to get better at
introspecting
that's cool so not having an agenda as
you go in
um increasingly i wonder if you've seen
this
curiosity is like this new buzzword
personality
trait um and i think one of the reasons
is that it does allow you to genuinely
be
interested in the outcome without
an agenda on your way through
and i think that's why it's quite useful
so yeah people need to try and
avoid going in with even with the hopes
of finding an answer
right because often that can cause you
as you said to kind of jump at the first
thing
which comes to them right moving moving
on to self-limiting beliefs
why why you put quite a bit of
importance
on these why are they so important
i think we tend to hold beliefs about
ourselves that really
lock us in to these patterns that that
that cause us to fall way short of our
potential right
i give examples like if you believe you
aren't the creative type
or if you even believe in the idea that
there are creative types and
non-creative types
uh then it will cause you not to explore
the opportunities that uh you know you
could be an incredible
creative person and you wouldn't know
because you've been telling yourself
this
story your whole life um you know
personally
i am very much naturally an introvert
uh i'm not i i could have very easily
got my whole life believing that i'm not
the kind of person who can do
public speaking who can go on podcasts
and talk about
my ideas right so if you have biases
that relate to
yourself and what you're capable of and
what kind of person you are
if there's a very good chance that
you're going to hold yourself back
from what you really are capable of so
so really i think it's important to put
these things
to the test and actually get out there
and and give
everything a fair shot before you decide
i'm not good at this
i'm not capable of that right you have
to
to take on the mindset of a scientist
and experiment
and see what you actually can do
so much of this is carried over from
childhood as well right
you had one crack at public speaking
in year 11 you know when you were
16 years old or 15 years old and that's
it i'm a crap public speaker for the
rest of my life
so hang on a second you wouldn't say
that you were the same person now as you
were back then for most other things in
your life
but you're right when it comes to the
self-limiting beliefs um
perhaps there's a little bit of safety
in there as well
that we can inoculate ourselves from
public failure by certifying
failure privately by simply not stepping
into the arena like you can't lose the
fight that you never
have a go at um yeah
self-limiting beliefs and that voice in
your head that is usually someone from
early in your childhood a parent
a younger an older brother or sister
some sort of teacher in school
for the most part they're just bollocks
and don't know what they're talking
about and they're no longer applicable
right right i mean i i often talk about
it as being your
default settings right the way that you
are right now is because of
that that's just your default settings
that's what you haven't programmed
yourself to be
and a lot of time these are programmed
at an early age when we're
in our childhood right you know it can
be initially programmed by
genetics by you know observing our
parents all these different
early experiences right but that's just
your
default setting right the the
experiences that you have and the
memories associated with them
serve to reprogram your anxieties and
your fears
right so the only way to actually get
past these things
is to get out of your comfort zone do
this thing that you've been telling
yourself
you're not capable of and it's sort of
it's sort of
the the output retrains the input right
the result
gives you new reference experiences so
you can actually
observe you can learn from your own
behavior and say oh i can do this
and read that belief and get rid of your
your fears
centered around it so right man i
ruptured an achilles last year
thought that my mental makeup would be
really bad
for that sort of an injury and i'd get
super depressed
and it was i was so much better than
even in my wildest dreams i could have
thought
that i didn't realize how much
resilience was there for me to tap into
and then when i needed it
it just arrived so i i really do think
that was
that was quite shocking to see and it
made me question a lot of my assumptions
around my
my own self-limiting beliefs as well
which i wouldn't advise
rupturing an achilles as a personal
development strategy but right now
at least the outcomes were okay so
moving on we've got we've got our
cognitive biases we've got rid of our
self-limiting beliefs as best we can
we've improved our introspection
then we need to cultivate self-mastery
and wisdom how do they
even how do people even start with doing
that
yeah i think wisdom is one of those
words that gets used for just about
everything
um and it's you have to make sure you're
on the same page when you're talking
about it
to me it's what you get when you combine
rationality
with that introspective clarity because
there are a lot of people out there who
are
who have gotten good at understanding
and getting what they want
but there's something still missing
right i mean
you know you were just talking about
these um
you know these setbacks like tearing
your achilles
right you can look at lottery winners
and and
quadriplegics or paraplegics and ask
you know how happy are they actually a
short while after
and the answer is like they're generally
the same it doesn't matter
yeah lottery winner and someone who's
disabled made disabled in a car crash
reset to the same level of happiness
after 12 months
right so so you have to question at that
point whether just
being rationally good at getting what
you want is actually
a good strategy for happiness right i
think wisdom
is being able to combine that rational
sort of strategic side
with the introspective clarity with the
knowledge about yourself that okay this
is
how my mind works this is how i think
things are going to go
and how i'm going to feel when this
happens this is why that may not be true
right if you if you take the classic
example
of whether you know you should take a a
wallet that you find or return it to the
owner
it's got a bunch of money in it right uh
strategically
you could say that of course you should
keep it right in in in a purely rational
like short-term sense right but i think
uh if you've got this introspective
clarity combined with it meaning you've
got wisdom you know that there are
there are other psychological outcomes
that could come from that
that these things that seem like they
would make you happy very often
uh don't make you happy and and we have
to we seem to have to keep relearning
these things over and over
so actually actually remembering the
next time you're in one of these cases
remembering that your new car didn't
actually
result in greater well-being that's
that's what it means to be wise i think
is is to hold those ideas in your head
the next time instead of just forgetting
again
so that's bayesian updating in a way
absolutely
it's just a more holistic uh version of
it applied to your whole life and your
mind
did you take your section on dukabias
from robert writes why buddhism is true
a big part of it yeah i mean i quoted
him in it yeah yeah so i
i got absolutely taunt pieces on youtube
for using the word unsatisfactoriness
really because someone was like duh it's
dissatisfaction and
somehow half of the internet decide on
an episode that went massive with
douglas murray
half of the internet decided that that
was the comment that they were going to
what vote i was like
i'm quoting someone else it's not my it
wasn't my fault it wasn't my word i
promise
can you just because i absolutely love
this story man can you explain what the
dukkha
bias is right so
dukkha is a buddhist term it's
essentially
the term for the problem with the human
condition uh
and it's been translated roughly as life
is suffering but that's not a very good
translation
uh unsatisfactoriness is uh is the best
comment comment and give him comment and
give ryan [ __ ] please thank you
yeah so unsatisfactory uh is the way the
buddha sort of
uh described uh life and the the human
condition and what's wrong with it is
essentially that
even when we get what we want uh there
is there is this longing that just never
goes away and and
from a modern perspective you could call
it hedonic adaptation
we don't actually get happier when we
get what we want
um so the buddha's solution to this was
to look at
uh this process of craving or thirsting
and try to completely
unplug it right he he said you know if
we can just
eliminate our desires completely then
that's that's sort of the way to end
uh this constant cycle of unhappiness
my approach is a little bit different i
say that that if you can learn to
manipulate
and and master your desires you can use
them
to fuel you towards your goals rather
than
than just preventing them from um
causing you to suffer
but you can do both essentially what's
an example of that
so with the kind of splitting two
different
sections so um an example with
for desire modulation um
so if you have a desire for
comfort and you you basically have this
need to be comfortable
all the time you're not capable of
enjoying
um you know a camping trip you're not
capable
of being content if the the temperature
in your house isn't set to the right
degree right and you recognize that this
is not really
this doesn't really matter this is this
is basically an addiction that i've
developed
all right you can basically do the
opposite using something called
asceticism
the stoics called it voluntary
discomfort right you can
go through this process of putting
yourself through something uncomfortable
so that you build up your resilience you
build up
your ability to adjust these desires
so if you can say like actually the life
that i want to live
will cause me to take risks it'll cause
me to step outside of my comfort zone
this need for comfort is holding me back
you can sort of counteract
that desire uh using a number of
different methods that i talk about
and then you can use uh different
desires to fuel you
towards your goals
the duka bias as you've called it is um
ever since i read that man in robert
wright's book
it's been one of those ground shake
moments
i think for the way that i view the
world um and the example i'm not sure if
it's him that uses it or if it's one
that i've come up with
he talks about imagine that you're
planning a holiday
and you can't wait for this holiday you
and your partner have been planning it
for ages you're going to be somewhere
hot and you
you've researched all the bars near the
hotel and you know you even know the
cocktail menu you know what cocktail
you're going to have
and the sun's going to set there and
that's the actual table i want to sit at
and for ages and ages you're thinking
about how beautiful it's going to be
and then you get there and you go away
on a holiday and it's the first night
and you've booked your table and it's
the exact table that you want and the
sun's just setting and you've got your
cocktail in your hand
but then you notice that there's some
grains of sand between your toes
and you think oh well that's a bit
irritating and i wish
i wish actually there's a little bit
less ice in my cocktail and i wonder
whether i should have had it
um shaken instead of blended and
actually the sun's a little bit low it's
kind of hurting my eyes i wish i'd
brought my and i wonder oh i've got some
sauce on my jacket
this isn't this is built into the source
code of how you see the world
if the first time that you caught a
bison or picked some berries
you were satisfied you would never get
another bison or pick another berry
so just realizing basically that
everything's going to be a bit
[ __ ] than you think it's going to be
and just
accepting that and being like look i can
enjoy this holiday i can get excited
about it
and know that when i get there there
will be sun between my toes there will
be this
but i have the perspective and this is
where it comes back to the mindfulness
gap or the metacognition in your
language
to just give us that buffer zone that
space to know
okay like this this doesn't matter that
the blend
the next one can be blended or or shaken
the
the sauce will come out of the top that
sand will come out of the toes like it's
sweet it's fine
um but yeah that's that bias
the duka bias is so awesome
i think everybody needs it in the in
their vocabulary
are you you talk about the the
pathologies of philosophers what do you
mean by that
yeah so there's kind of this tendency
that that we all have and i call it that
specifically because philosophers like
nietzsche and schopenhauer
uh often often lean on this side
right but it kind of glorifies suffering
and we see this today by saying that
like
great people or creative people are the
ones who suffer the most
and it kind of allows us to justify uh
unnecessary parts of the human
experience i'm not saying that suffering
can never be useful for bringing about a
good result
or that you can't even necessarily
completely eliminate suffering but i
think
by and large our negative emotions uh
really do hold us back and they keep us
locked in
things that aren't good for us long term
so you know on on one end nietzsche
talks about
uh how you know if you want to be happy
then believe
he's talking about like religious belief
and faith if you want to
um if you want to be incisive if you
want to
understand the world then inquire right
and he kind of
in doing that suggests that people who
are
uh who have incisive beliefs who see the
world clearly
must not be happy and these kind of
happy go look the go lucky dogmatists
are the ones who are actually happy
because they don't see the world clearly
and i kind of call this into question
and say no you can develop incisive
beliefs and be happy that this is not a
contrast
it's a it's a defense mechanism that
people who are smart
put up to justify you know depression
and despair and negative
moods right this cynicism and then the
same is done for
effectiveness like i said with with
creatives right we say that you have to
suffer in order to be
great right you you have to go through
this negative emotion
and very often negative emotion is
useless it doesn't serve
it doesn't serve us it doesn't make us
great um
you know there are exceptions i think
but generally
you should try to get rid of any
negative
emotions that cause you to suffer and
you shouldn't worry about
shouldn't worry that you won't be able
to achieve your goals or you won't be
able to see the world clearly right you
can work on all these
different fronts and develop mastery in
each individual area
that's such a blind spot that i think a
lot of people who enjoy
a particularly existential philosophy
but anyone that's kind of in the
rationality movement
they and i i find this in myself this is
a bias i have myself that
the puritan work ethic that's been baked
into us in the west
just sees the suffering as you know it's
in service to some higher power
and you don't actually think well is
there a is there an easier way to do
this
or a more a happier way is there a
happier way for me to achieve the same
thing
and part of you says because culturally
and
and maybe even genetically as well
you've got it in your head you're like
well
maybe i don't want it to be easier
because maybe if it was easier
i wouldn't i wouldn't do it as much
anymore i wouldn't be as effective or
something else there's just an aversion
to it being
not painful yeah yeah it's interesting
just just
i've seen it all the time on internet
forums i've heard people in interviews
say like i don't necessarily want to get
rid of my anger or my anxiety there you
know i'm all about getting stuff done
it's like you you can you don't have to
choose between those two outcomes like
anger isn't a very good
motivator right lao tzu said uh the best
fighter is never angry
so if even fighting doesn't benefit from
anger even if you're trying to punch
someone in the face
and being angry yeah it makes you worse
at it
what an awesome example i mean as well
like
think about i i often think about this a
lot of the time
people justify discomfort
enroute to a goal which actually
undercuts the achievement of the goal
itself it's like
i need to be angry or anxious in order
to be creative
why do you want to be creative well i
want to be creative because i want to be
successful why do you want to be
successful i want to be successful
because i want to be happy can you be
happy if you're anxious or angry
no right okay in that case the first
step the thing that you are using to
fuel your development
is limiting your ability to reach your
goal
absolutely yeah you have to keep in mind
what the ultimate goal is there are more
direct means to get what you want and
we're so trained that we have to do this
whole
roundabout process in order to just be
happy
if you just go straight to the source
and work on your mind
you can you can build a lot of that
happiness in and then you can
you can go towards things you can work
towards things
out of a love for the process rather
than because you're so eager to get the
results because it's going to make you
happy
is equanimity desirable because if
people don't really care about what
happens maybe they're not being
motivated to go do anything anymore
i i definitely think it's desirable and
i think
really i make this contrast between
desires and values
specifically for this reason because if
you don't have
any negative emotions causing you to
suffer
that doesn't necessarily mean you aren't
going to do anything i didn't write this
book
out of a desire to escape all the bad
feelings that i had from not having
written a book
right you we have these intrinsic
motivations
that push us to do things and if you
want to be able to tap into those
intrinsic drives
i think you do need to develop a certain
level of stability into your own mind
you need to get to where your
conflicting
emotions and drives aren't pulling you
in all different directions so that you
can actually focus
on the things that you really value and
the the direction you really want to go
in
uh rather than just what you feel like
at any given time
how do people achieve equanimity how do
we turn down the volume of those
different pulls and emotions
so a lot of philosophies have have
suggested that there's this one
core problem at the root of our minds
right whether it's our
ego or whatever it may be i kind of take
a different
approach based on evolutionary
psychology and i say look all of these
different forms of suffering exist in
our mind for different reasons
right diff because they caused us to we
get jealous because
you know it helps us to retain mates
from a biological perspective we get
angry because it helps us preserve our
status
you know we have all of these different
things that aren't necessarily that
relevant to us today
and i think we have to look at each of
them a la carte and we say how do i how
does this work
what is the structure of the algorithm
causing me to get angry or jealous and
how can i rework
it so so it's very much a creative
design
process that you have to apply to every
different struggle
like i said you you may find when you
really observe your emotions
that 90 comes from the same mental
process
so you have to look at what it is that
is that is preventing you
from from tranquility and you have to
work on that specific
issue and really figure out how it works
so you can rework it
similar to the way that you advise
people to go about the cognitive biases
at the start
absolutely that that's kind of the idea
behind psychic texture and the reason
that's
the word for it because it is a creative
design
process comparable to architecture or
something you are
you are looking at each psychological
issue
as its own creative problem-solving
challenge to tackle
evolutionary psychology for me is
the emotional equivalent of learning
mental models
yeah i mean absolutely like as you're
reading well this is why you have
envy this is why friendship exists this
is what reciprocal altruism means this
is what kinship is
this is why men are attracted to women
that are younger than them and women are
attracted to men that have v-shaped
bodies and why we like good teeth and
why we like good hair and
why we have an aversion to things that
are colored blue and that we try and eat
them and no one will do it
all of this stuff um yeah it really is
peering into the source code in a way
that uh i don't think many other
many of the subject areas allow us to do
you're right i mean most if you just
search like why do people get jealous
you're not going to find a lot of
results actually telling you why
we biologically have these tendencies
right they often start way later than
that but to me
this is this is where you have to start
you have to look at
why we're wired the way we are so you
know what function these things are
meant to serve
not necessarily for us because very
often it isn't good for us
but for our genes and for our ability to
to propagate our genes essentially
so we've got cognitive we've got
emotional that's done
and then the third section is behavioral
so what are the impediments to
self-direction
so i list four major impediments
right you've got uh you've got
corruption
you've got compliance which is our
tendency to go along with
what everyone else is doing right you've
got craving which is the most
obvious right our addiction to to
different chemicals
and you've got comfort which is a huge
one so
i i examine each of these and and the
basic obstacles that they pose and how
you can
work around them all right i talk a lot
about
um how our our cravings are amplified by
the modern world how
modern food for example kind of hijacks
our our evolutionary
you know desire for certain nutrients
how modern social media
hijacks our social drive uh so a lot of
for his work against us um
and and preventing us from living the
life that we really choose
to live but i think the best solution
still rests in self-mastery i call it
in the ability to develop more control
over your mind
so in the whole behavioral section
i talk about these different creative
strategies
to rework your behaviors and your habits
rather than just kind of trying to brute
force suppress the things you don't want
to do and and work up the motivation to
do the things that you do
what are some of your favorite
strategies from that
so if you look at the classic
marshmallow
test by walter mitchell which found that
self-control is is pretty much the
greatest determinant
of success in life out of any other
metric uh even like intelligence and sat
scores
a lot of people assume that means that
people who have more willpower
are are just going to be better at
things in life and the reality is
i think the people who have a lot of
self-control
aren't necessarily gritting their teeth
and using a lot of willpower
they're using these strategies so even
in that example with the marshmallow
test
the kids who were able to not eat the
marshmallow for longer that was sitting
in front of them
they weren't the ones who were staring
the marshmallow down and trying to fight
back the urges
they were the ones who were either
directing their attention somewhere else
playing with a toy doing something
besides
staring at the marshmallow or they were
altering their
evaluation right their interpretation
they were thinking about the marshmallow
as
a cloud or something instead of as a
delicious treat
and and really you can you can take a
lot of ideas from this
and apply it to your own life um in
terms of
designing the consequences of your
actions
right you can you can use the desires
that you already have
to channel the behavior that you want so
a lot of us have heard
of the idea of you know writing a check
to a friend
and having them deposit it if we don't
meet our goals right this is using
our desire to maintain our money and
accumulate things financially right you
can also use your social drive right so
everything from
uh you know having a workout buddy or a
personal trainer if you want to exercise
i personally have used a tool that i
love called focus mate
i use this in the process of writing the
book where basically
you you meet with people virtually you
have these
hour long roughly calls and it calls
itself a virtual co-working tool you
basically just check in at the beginning
tell the person what you want to
accomplish over the next hour
and they tell you theirs and then you
check back in at the end to see how you
you do and every time i've done this i
have ended up
meeting my goal of word count or
whatever it is that i was trying to do
it is a surprisingly powerful tool and
it's because we're not just trying to to
push through and get it done
we're using desires that are already
inside of us
to make it a lot easier and sort of turn
it into the path of least resistance
what's the opposite of self-mastery
so i call it self-slavery and it's
essentially
what i argue is not only uh responsible
for
you know being unhappy and and not
having self-control or clarity
right but it really i think explains a
lot of the evil in the world
um or what we tend to call evil
so you know a lot of the people who do
some of the worst things
i think are unable to control their
desires or they're unable to get
the clarity needed to work towards
what they really value so i mean you can
apply this
anywhere from like dictators who believe
they're doing something good for the
world but they've got
this bias and this lack of wisdom um
to you know something like school
shooters who who simply
haven't developed the mastery over uh
admittedly difficult emotions that
they're
often going through so if we started
looking at things like this and we
started saying how can we
give people the tools they need to to
restructure their minds
and and ignite their interest in
restructuring their minds
i think it would reduce a lot of the the
bad actors that we see in society that
we often just blame on this
enigmatic evil inside of them yeah
you're very correct i think it's odd in
a meritocracy
that we don't believe that people can
have redemption
with that do you understand what i mean
there's kind of a bit of a juxtaposition
there if you are
if anyone can become anything that they
want and hard work can get you anywhere
the winners at the top are worthy of
their successes and the losers at the
bottom
are worthy of their failures it does
seem odd that we're not empowering
people
to take control of their own mental
architecture
more with stuff like this i i agree
i totally agree the whole justice system
is kind of centered around
just deciding who the good guys and the
bad guys are and making sure the bad
guys
suffer uh rather than figuring out how
we can cultivate these better qualities
in people
have you heard sam harris's most recent
free will the final word on free will
podcast that he put out last week i have
not heard it yet
dude you will love it anybody that's
listening after this
go and have a listen to that um so sam's
been big into
determinism kind of one of the the
public facing
um forefronts of that i suppose and he
just does an hour and a half monologue
talking about every single different
element of it it's so beautiful
he really is he's wonderful to listen to
i know that
his um views on trump have annoyed some
people over the last
year or so but man when you get him in
his
wheelhouse for stuff like that he's
unbeatable
there was this quote actually in the
book where you say that
if losing all of your possessions
circumstances
social standing and relationships would
deprive you of all your happiness
what you have cannot be called happiness
in the first place
do you think that that's a desirable
state to get to where we're so detached
from our externalities from our external
world
that were kind of um
totally floating through in this
oddly diogenes sort of piss pot of
of self discare about the world
i don't think that's a desirable kind of
life no and and i really
am not referring to uh to that kind of
lifestyle where you you
want to get rid of your um relationships
and possessions and all that
right but what i'm i'm really getting at
there is that if you haven't
built the the psychological well-being
into your mind then you're essentially
going to be hopeless if you don't have
all these things
that you have come to require you know i
think
i think you should work towards a life
that embodies your values whatever that
is
so if that involves you know close
relationships and altruism and that kind
of thing
which i assume it does for for just
about everyone
then that's the kind of life you should
lead but but you shouldn't do it because
you need those things to make you happy
and you're you're
unable to enjoy your life without them
right you should do it because that's
the life you want to have that's the
person you want to be
you know i don't i don't talk about how
you can algorithmically program
joy and love into your mind so you don't
need to have
anyone else in your life right i haven't
found a way to do that
i'm mostly focused on how to get rid of
the
obstacles in your own mind uh preventing
you from enjoying
this world and and and fully diving into
those positive things
yeah it's it's interesting thinking
about i know you've read the happiness
hypothesis by john hate
and he talks about happiness doesn't
just come from within it comes from
within and without
and there's a a quote from naval that's
floating around online my buddy vizzy
has just done a drawing for him which is
beautiful um
if you go on at n-a-v-a-l on instagram
you can see the drawing that i'm i'm
talking about now
and the quote is it is far easier to
achieve your material desires than to
renounce them
and i think that the devil lies in the
details when we're having this
discussion
asceticism and the rise of minimalism
the minimalist movement where people
just get rid of all of their possessions
and live out of a backpack
um that world kind of this
um almost going back to the cynicism
right of of ancient
the ancient world um i think that that
is in a way people deciding to not
step into the arena of
real world success that as i said before
you can inoculate yourself from failure
in the real world by deciding never to
put the
coin in the machine and play the game um
and the the devil is in the details in
that you need
to try and cultivate personal values a
sense of sovereignty
this robustness around yourself and
resilience and fortitude
to the things that the world is
inevitably going to throw at you both
good and bad
and know that what happens to you the
things that occur to you like that
do not matter and yet in the same breath
you can also
enjoy having a family driving a nice car
being in a comfortable house getting to
go away on a holiday
and i wonder if in a different version
of the simulation
we would actually be able to construct a
society that was ubi'd up to the max
and didn't have this puritan work ethic
or was we were all
david pierced up with intravenous mdma
in a transhumanist utopia where we don't
even need other people around you know i
mean
but this is the world that we've got the
world that we've got right now is a
meritocracy it is something where you
need to go out and do stuff we still
have mental programming
that gives you a sense of what is pride
like why do we have pride we have pride
because when you do something
challenging and worthwhile you get
a good feeling to yourself because you
are moving toward a goal
not having goals isn't an option you're
always going to have goals even if the
goal is to not have goals you're
constantly going to be checking
teleologically against whether or not
you're achieving that have i not
achieved a goal today
no right yes well no dude that's a goal
like it's
kind of a bit unfalsifiable in that way
but yeah man the devil really is in the
details of this and i think you've done
for anybody that wants to enjoyed what
we've gone through today
designing the mind the principles of
psychiatry will be linked in the show
notes below
you've done a like a really really
awesome job with it dude
um as a sort of a parting note how can
people continue to optimize their mental
software moving
forward awesome yeah
so what i would tell you is that if you
want to follow what designing the mind
is doing
you can go to designingthemind.org i'm
going to be sharing
a lot of ideas related to psychitecture
and all this
to anyone who joins the email list
but but i also want to do a lot of big
things
in the near future and to help me do
that i've created a survey
where i'm essentially trying to figure
out what people's
psychological struggles and aspirations
are what comes up the most so i know
what to focus in depth on
and i'm also doing a giveaway centered
around that so i'm giving away signed
copies of the book
i'm giving away a few other
psychological tools
so if you go to designingthemind.org
survey you can fill that out you'll be
entered into the giveaway and added to
the email
list you can unsubscribe anytime but i
would
i would love to be able to uh welcome
you to a
a really cool community in the near
future
i love it man thank you uh final thing
what is
a underground hero book
that you stumbled upon whilst
researching
uh designing the mind that you think
more people should know about
good question um so one thing that comes
to mind
uh i don't know how underground it is
but uh
a couple books by maslow beyond just um
you know the hierarchy of needs that
everyone's familiar with
uh you know the farther reaches of human
nature
just an incredible vision of what uh the
human mind is capable of
so uh i would highly recommend that or
or towards the psychology of being by
maslow
um there's a one really underground
thing that isn't even technically a book
it's like a document floating on the
internet
called the nine levels of increasing
embrace by suzanne cook reuter
and this doesn't show up in this book
but
it's a very interesting perspective on
the mind and the way that we
develop and mature so i i cannot
recommend that highly enough
awesome i'm going to try and find the
nine levels of increasing embrace and if
anyone wants to check it out
it may be in the show notes below or i
may not have i may have given up um
ryan man i'm super excited for whatever
the next book is and whatever you've got
coming up i really look forward to it
awesome yeah thanks so much for having
me man i really enjoyed it
[Music]